bonjour à tous alors
oui j'ai eu la chance j'ai été choisi ce
soir pour être le speaker étudiants de
l'essec
mais après très honnêtement en fait
étudiants de l'essec
c'était pas vraiment le plan que j'avais
prévu à la base en fait jusqu'à mes 16
ans environ je pensais plutôt être
musicien c'est le milieu que j'ai un peu
toujours connu mon père et hautboïste ma
mère fait aussi de la musique est donc
naturellement j'ai commencé le basson
très jeune vers 6-7 ans en fait c'est
vraiment un milieu que je connaissais
bien et où je savais comment réussir où
j'étais finalement privilégié en
primaire puis ensuite au collège j'avais
un emploi du temps aménagé ce qui me
permettait d'aller au conservatoire
d'après-midi et de travailler mon
instrument au lycée je faisais
régulièrement des concerts et j'allais
en stage l'été pour permettre de
rencontrer des musiciens connus et
d'aprr d'approfondir encore ma pratique
instrumentale
c'était vraiment la voie toute tracée
j'étais sur des rails je connaissais
énormément de gens qui faisait ce métier
là et qui voulait me donner des conseils
et c'est un peu voilà la voie qui était
fait pour moi finalement mais à un
moment je me suis senti que j'ai senti
que c'était pas vraiment là où moi je
voulais aller là où je m'épanouis ray le
plus est que correspondrait le mieux à
ce que je voulais faire et donc j'ai
fait un peu un virage à 180 degrés et
j'ai suivi une voie qui était beaucoup
plus classique pour beaucoup de gens en
fait j'ai fait une classe préparatoire
scientifique puis au bout de deux ans de
boulot à ces acharnés je suis rentré à
centrale alors honnêtement quand je me
vois aujourd'hui rentré à centrale je
pense un peu à ça en fait à la fois j'ai
l'impression de pouvoir faire plein de
choses et d'avoir une vraie liberté et
en même temps quand j'y repense
aujourd'hui j'étais un bébé
en fait pendant ces trois ans qui me
séparent de centrales à aujourd'hui
viendront avoir énormément appris je
pense que vraiment c'est une période
charnière où on se construit
en tant qu'individu et en tant qu'adulte
et cette peur d'école elle va nous
marquer toute notre vie est ce que je
retiens
finalement c'est moins des cours que
tout l'extra scolaire est
particulièrement tout l'univers
associatif
en fait ce qui est intéressant c'est que
je vous partage pas là seulement une
histoire personnelle mais en fait c'est
un phénomène historique qu'a lieu qui a
donné lieu à ça dans les années 80-90
tout le monde des grandes écoles a subi
une contrainte du monde économique en
fait on a demandé à ces écoles d'art
était de former uniquement des grands
scientifiques des grands académiciens et
les grands chercheurs mais aussi de
préparer leurs étudiants à la viande
entreprises à passer au delà ça a été un
petit peu la panique dans les écoles
parce que tout d'un coup on devait non
seulement transmettre des savoirs et
donner toutes les connaissances
académiques aux étudiants pour réussir
mais en plus de cela on devait les
former au management à la gestion de
projet et plus généralement essayé de
leur donner ces choses un peu en
palpable qu'on appelle les savoir-être
et la solution qu'elle ait trouvé par
les écoles c'est les associations en
fait les écoles sont venus promouvoir
les initiatives étudiantes et les
projets étudiants pour leur promettre
pour leur proposer de tester ce qui eu
leur tenait à coeur
c'est l'occasion de se tester un petit
peu justement dans cette gestion de
projet et de devenir même si avec
d'autres étudiants une sorte de manager
et finalement ça a marché assez bien et
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui si vous
écoutez n'importe quel discours de
directeur par exemple lors de la rentrée
si vous prenez n'importe quel plaquettes
marketing qui distribue dans les classes
préparatoires ou même au lycée ou encore
si vous écoutez un étudiant comme moi
vous parler de son expérience à l'école
ils ont à peu près le même discours en
deux mots ce qui vous diront c'est que
les associations font partie intégrante
de la formation
c'est vraiment là où la plupart des
choses se jouent là où se créent la
plupart des relations sociales et là où
finalement se fera réellement notre
formation
ce qu'on nous dit un peu moins
c'est que tout si l'association ne se
valent pas entre elles il y en a
certaines qui vont être plus renommés
que d'autres et qui vont permettre une
meilleure visibilité dans l'école il y
en a d'autres qui vont être plus proche
du monde professionnel et donc qui vont
permettre aux étudiants qu'ils intègrent
de créer très tôt un réseau et de mieux
connaître le monde de l'entreprise ce
qui leur permettra ensuite d'être mieux
recruter
ce qui est particulièrement intéressant
c'est que les étudiants qui aujourd'hui
ont des postes à responsabilité au sein
des grosses associations sont aussi des
étudiants qui vont être plus tard mieux
recruter et une étude d'un sociologue
français qui s'appelle gilles lazuech
qui montrent que ces étudiants ont une
meilleure mobilisation pour l'emploi
une meilleure connaissance des métiers
qui les intéresse et que finalement ils
peuvent arriver à des plus hauts postes
et par exemple si on prend bien en
termes ancien pdg monde d'accenture ou
encore thierry fritsch pdg monte de
chaud mais on a certes deux ans un échec
mais aussi deux anciens et seck ancien
membre de la générale entreprises c'est
à dire l'association une des
associations en tout cas les plus
renommés et le plus proche de son
professionnel et je pense qu'à un moment
ça a pu avoir son importance
un moment peut-être sous revue se
sont-ils vus proposer plus
d'opportunités de pas leur appartenance
à cette association ou en tout cas par
les formations qu'ils en retirent est le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que l'accès à
ces associations et au poste
particulièrement responsabilité il n'est
pas libre souvent pour rentrer il ya une
sélection de la part des 2e année qui
choisissent les premières années ou
encore si vous voulez être président il
ya une élection au sein de vos camarades
pour savoir si effectivement vous
correspondez à l'idée qu'on se fait du
poste
le problème avec tout ça c'est qu'on va
venir sans même y faire attention et
sans y réfléchir reproduire des schémas
un peu préconçues et finalement percuter
des inégalités je m'explique
par exemple si vous êtes d'une famille
plus modestes vous avez moins de chance
de vous engager dans l'associatif et
encore moins de prendre un poste à
responsabilités comme président alors il
ya des arguments purement financiers
peut-être que vous allez devoir
travailler ou se promener l'alternance
pour payer vos études ce qui va limiter
votre temps disponible pour les
associations
peut-être encore allez vous être un peu
plus réticents à vous inscrire aux
différents événements payants et qui en
même temps font de la communauté des
élèves
donc je pense aux soirées au week-end
ski ou que sais-je
mais finalement et des causes un peu
plus profonde que ça en fait finalement
dans la construction même de votre
identité vous allez probablement moins
match et avec ce qu'on attend du
président un peu parfait ou du bode donc
du cool un peu parfait en fait ce qu'on
a montré c'est que en général en grandes
écoles
quelqu'un qui travaille trop c'est pas
très net enfin même un nom s'appelle le
polar le polar c'est un peu cette figure
que personne ne veut être c'est ce mec
qui n'a pas compris que la prépa aux us
et terminé et qu'ils continuent à
s'investir complètement dans les cours
c'est quelqu'un qui finalement passé un
petit peu à côté de tout l'extra
scolaire de tout ce qui est nouveau dans
les grandes écoles et qui se consacre
uniquement sa réussite académique est ce
qu'on a remarqué c'est que les étudiants
de milieux plus modestes avaient
tendance à placer justement ce travail
cette académique comme une valeur plus
importante que ces étudiants privilégiés
ça s'explique si sedan sont là où ils
sont aujourd'hui
c'est aussi parce que ils ont eu des
résultats académiques très très bon et
si c'était pas leur milieu ils ont
peut-être dû donner un peu plus pour
réussir et donc de fil en aiguille ce
convoi en deux mots c'est que si vous
êtes une famille modeste
vous avez beaucoup plus de chances
d'être un polar et de la ne jamais
devenir président de l'association on a
un mécanisme un peu
similaire avec la représentation des
filles plus globalement en fait par
exemple si on prend à l'essec
les trois dernières années deux
présidents sur trois sont des hommes
pourtant la promo et environs mixte
voire même il ya un petit peu plus de
filles et ça paraît inexplicable
il semble pas y avoir de discrimination
contre les femmes
ou en tout cas pas explicite en fait on
n'est même pas sûr que les femmes soient
moins élus lorsqu'elle se présente
le problème c'est toujours le même c'est
con à ses conceptions du président
parfait du cool parfait d'une botte
parfait et que les femmes usuellement
s'ils reconnaissent un petit peu moins
et en fait que je voudrais vous dire ce
soir c'est qu'on a le pouvoir de changer
les choses
en fait nous étudiants on est
aujourd'hui face à des choix dans nos
associations qui vont nous permettre de
réduire durablement les inégalités y a
pas besoin d'attendre dix ans j'ai
peut-être dans ma salle le prochain des
rages total le prochain membre du comex
d'orange ou encore le prochain
responsable de la diversité chez l'oréal
est en fait je réalise dès maintenant on
peut agir au coeur même de l'endroit où
sont formés les élites c'est à dire les
associations on peut donner cette chance
à quelqu'un a peut-être un peu moins de
gérer un projet de s'affirmer en tant
que manager et finalement de gagner une
confiance en lui ou en elle qui va lui
rester toute sa vie
alors posons nous des questions
remettons en question nos idées reçues
demandons-nous finalement qu'est ce que
l'on voit derrière un polar des requins
qui travaillent ou encore d'ailleurs un
président quelqu'un qui a des
responsabilités
arrêtons de penser que quelqu'un parce
qu'il est investi au rugby ne peut pas
être féministe ou encore investir au
développement durable et enfin cessant
de prendre des gens simplement parce
qu'il nous ressemble
si on arrive à faire cela nous étudiants
on arrivera à réduire les inégalités et
aucun autre formation d' apprendre
réellement ce que c'est
la diversité merci pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]